The joe rogan experience.
So,
um,
so I got an injected and that was um,
first of all looked like it got like run over by a semi truck for like two days.
It was like all black and blue or the injection you serve was,
yeah,
yeah.
I'd be super nervous.
Like what do you got infected it,
it could have gotten infected
that cancer.
I've had Marissa and I would not wish Murcia on your Dick.
I didn't get mercy a triathlon.
I,
I got it.
This was at though at the wildflower triathlon,
like coming back,
my flight got delayed and I was covering all these kids like an off road
triathlon and I had all these scrapes and wounds and I think,
I think my labor was in Vegas,
I don't remember where,
but I had to check into a hotel.
Flight got delayed and I slept in this hotel room that I swear like there must
have been something on the bed because within a few days like it was all,
you know,
it gets all nasty and cakey and then it was eating a whole,
I wrote a whole blog post about this on my website and they see,
you can see pull up the hole in the back of my leg.
It's nasty.
Scares the shit out of him.
Just just search for like Ben Greenfield staff and you'll see the pictures.
But it was eating a whole in the back of my leg and my,
my kids role now,
once a week and I buy,
I get the,
the defense soap from on it.
As soon as they come,
as soon as they come back in the door,
I have them go into the shower upstairs and defense and writes down.
Yeah.
They have a bunch of different wipes and stuff for people that train in a place
that doesn't have a a shower.
Yeah.
You gotta be careful.
Uh,
thieves essential oil.
Like it's like going to like a whole bunch of companies make this version of
essential oil called thieves.
It's like clove and roads named after these thieves who apparently never got
clove.
Cinnamon Eucalyptus,
which is really good for staff and Rosemay.
It's actually named it.
There's like this story of like these four thieves that apparently traveled
around the world and they would rob Holmes and,
and,
and they never got sick.
Like that's basically the story.
I'm sure this was,
this was some board table at a,
at a multilevel marketing essential oils company.
Somebody came up with this story or it could be true.
I don't know.
But the um,
yeah,
the,
the stem cells into the Dick that that was an interesting one,
but it did.
Um,
I think from what I can tell,
looking in the mirror,
it got bigger.
I'm pretty sure how much,
so half inch,
oh.
Like maybe that much like enough to tell and my erections got bigger and my
orgasms got a lot better for how long they are still like that.
Well,
people don't take what they have right in front of them.
Seriously enough.
It's like the wasting time thing.
They don't do the arithmetic,
you know,
when they also don't understand,
they devalue what they have right in front of them.
Like another,
another client I worked with was having a hard time putting his kid to bed at
night.
And so we did the arithmetic.
It's like,
well I'm fighting with my kid for 45 minutes a night trying to get them to go to
bed.
Okay,
so let,
let's analyze that.
All right,
so what does that mean?
Well,
it means that both of you end the day upset.
That's not so good cause why would you want that?
It means that you're spending 45 minutes fighting when you could spend 20
minutes doing something
positive.
Like reading to them say means that you don't get to spend that time with your
wife.
So she's not very happy with you.
Plus you're annoyed because you don't see her.
Plus do you blame it on the kid?
Because he's the proximal cause.
It's like that's pretty damn ugly.
And then,
and then let's do the arithmetic.
It's like seven days a week,
45 minutes a day.
Let's call that five hours,
20 hours a week,
240 hours in a year.
It's six.
You're spending a month and a half of work weeks fighting with your four year
old son.
I think you're going to like them.
You don't like anyone.
You spend a month and a half a year fighting with.
It's a bad idea.
Fix it.
It's important.
Get them to bed,
make it peaceful.
You do it like these things that repeat every single day.
That's a Motif in this book to your life isn't Marguerite is on a beach in
Jamaica that happens now in that those are exceptions.
You're life is how your wife greets you at the door when you come home every day
cause that's like 10 minutes a day.
Your life is how you treat each other over the breakfast table cause that's an
hour and a half or an hour every single day.
You get those mundane things right?
Those things you do every day,
you've concentrated on them and you make them pristine.
It's like you got 80% of your life put together.
These little things that are right in front of us.
They're not little.
That's the first thing.
They are not little and they're hard to set.
Right.
And if you set them right,
it has a rippling effect and fast to way faster than people think.
But
people were sending me messages,
blood's on your hands and this.
Now I'm like,
if you went out and had unprotected Buzzcocks after listening to the Joe Rogan
experience,
you deserve what's coming.
Yeah.
Okay.
If you listen to me and you're like,
that's it,
Peter Duesberg,
right.
Send it in.
Rex spot is go.
I'm odd man.
You can't demonize conversations.
And I don't know enough about the subject,
but I listened to that guy's take on it.
And it's fuel for thought.
You know,
I don't think he's right.
I don't,
but I,
I've talked to a lot of people that I don't figure,
right.
I think I've talked to some crazy fucking people on the show and I think you
gotta be able to have conversations.
You have to,
well,
I mean we might agree on 60% of things,
maybe 50,
maybe get somewhere between 40 and 70.
I don't know.
It doesn't matter.
It should be okay.
But it should be totally fine.
And that's the thing when we do,
uh,
you know,
the change my mind segments,
most time people,
it's pretty amicable and then you just get someone who comes up and wants to
commit assault the trickling puffs.
And it's like,
I think a big skill,
we've kind of had to learn this because not Jared knows.
Um,
when we first had guests,
if it was,
if it was a guest we just agreed with,
I was like,
listen,
I will not edit you.
It will not be taken out of context.
But I would sit down for three hours with them because they would be like,
don't cut me off.
Don't come up.
And you realize it just repeating themselves.
So finding the balance of saying there are a lot of people out there now who are
open to hearing these points of you who are open to hearing these ideas.
Being able to identify them and then being able to identify the people who are
so bought in,
they won't even listen.
You need to make an example of them for the people you can convince.
Right.
And understanding the two different kinds of people,
the,
the trigger,
the puffs versus uh,
you know,
I don't know,
Jordan Peterson.
You'll probably never saw himself as even political at all until he came out and
said something that would seem to be so benign and caused an uproar.
Um,
I think being able to identify those two,
it's not so much just about left and right.
Who can hear who won't and how to handle them.
Right.
And why,
why can't you hear?
Can you not hear because it interferes with your ideology or can you not hear?
Because what they're saying is illogical.
Like which one is it?
Is it,
are you honestly listening to what they're saying?
And can you give factual refute?
Can you give some sort of a factual review of this?
Or is it just,
it just doesn't jive with your view of the world you have.
You have some rock solid view of the world that you're not,
uh,
you're not willing to look at any other perspectives.
So I had that big of a decision because the colorful kids didn't get no pussy.
They just wanted to post.
They would talk about girls and they may be had a crush on the girl and the four
30 class,
but then the rest of the company,
any of the events,
my other buddies,
one the buzzy.
So eventually I cut the karate fucking geeks out and I started hanging out with
a little druggies.
And you make your transition from those developmental ages.
Like I tried to hide my drug use.
I tried to hide,
especially with marijuana use for two or three years.
It was just marijuana.
While then,
once I became a freshman and got it and start basketball my freshman year,
I decided to let's venture out into this acid thing.
Let's venture until this masculine thing.
It was a different name.
It was masculine,
but it really wasn't Mescalin Joe Rogan.
It was a little tag Elodie it would know it wasn't even pay on.
It was a little thing I did the same,
excuse me.
Yeah,
Mba,
but masculine is what they sell you in the south.
They supposedly put it in Tequila or something.
This was Sao,
right?
Yeah,
and this is something that tube,
a little fucking white kids made in a pill.
It was rat poison with something else and something else and it was very tiny.
It was maybe a little size of this.
That's it.
And it came in aluminum foil.
Even smaller than that.
Wow.
Way Smaller,
that little thing that that's it.
You paid $80 for it and you got a hundred of those and you start looking at $3 a
piece and that would fuck you up for six hours with a two hour Hayes in between
an hour buffer.
I want to come down and I did that for three or four months.
Then they introduced me to THC crystal,
which is snorting.
They sold it as,
what we do is we got a bunch of stems and seeds from the reefer.
We put it in a pot and we boil that pot and whatever separate from the stems and
the that goes to the sides.
We scraped that off.
And that's where you snot in your nose.
Oh my God.
So I was,
I was,
I had like a personal karate rule,
but I would always just smoke it and do the masculine,
but I was never going to put nothing in my nose.
Oh you had a rule like a drug addict puts something in their nose.
Right?
Like that's it.
Like that's a complete different range.
I'll never shoot heroin and I'll never put,
especially at my karate man as a carotid man.
Right.
Carotid morals.
Yeah.
I was just straight away with the reefer and then I finally ended up snoring
that fucking gorilla biscuits shit.
Cause that's what it was.
It was angel dust.
They just like God told you.
And I went on an angel dust tab.
Like every Sunday me and my friend Carlos Perez would buy a six pack of
Michelob.
He only like Mick,
a low.
He has to have good friends die.
This kind of special to appear with the beer.
Will Pour,
must say something more
call.
It's about as low and brow.
A little brown.
Are we talking about Michelob?
Michelob?
No.
We would drink Lowell brown.
[inaudible].